hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about grammar now
often here at my channel there has been
discussion of you know the importance of
input and the need to de-emphasize
grammar instruction when it comes to
language learning and this very often
causes a great debate between those
people who love grammar and those people
who are averse to learning grammar so I
want to talk a little bit about grammar
and how it relates now to my most recent
language which is Romanian and of course
every language we learn is different for
us because in each case we either know a
related language or don't know a related
language there is common vocabulary with
languages that we know or there isn't
so Romanian obviously is very different
from Korean or Russian or Czech because
in Romanian there's you know whatever
3/4 of the words are more or less
recognizable as being similar to
vocabulary that I already know in other
Romance languages so that makes it very
different from learning Korean Chinese
or Slavic languages the other thing
that's different about Romanian for me
this time is that I want to learn it in
a hurry because I'm gonna be in Romania
for 3 days only and I just want to be
able to communicate while I'm there and
understand as much as possible
normally my strategy is to just sit back
and let it come at me with the intention
of eventually achieving a high level of
comprehension in the language and also
the ability to communicate with you know
people who have common interests I don't
think that in the six weeks that I have
I'm gonna be able to achieve that in
Romanian so and of course when I started
we didn't have a lot of content at link
so I went and got Pimsleur as I've
talked and I explained and then I went
and got teach yourself and I've been
using both of those I also was able to
get ahold of a very good grammar book
for Romanian so I want to talk about how
I use that book and how it relates to
my language learning and what I think is
the ideal way to tackle grammar first of
all I have never said that one should
not look at grammar I have always said
that we look at grammar from time to
time we look at the tables we look at
the rules but we don't expect to learn
it we don't expect to learn the table at
least I don't expect to learn the table
when I look at the table I don't think
it's possible to nail down the basics so
that then they're solid and then you can
just go on and learn words I find that
the grammar sort of drips in bit by bit
things start to become clearer over time
and as part of the puzzle becomes
clearer some other parts then are more
accessible and it's difficult to predict
what's going to be difficult in what's
going to be easy for example you know
present tense past tense
it may not be difficult to learn both
those things at the same time but some
issues relating to pronouns might be
very difficult to grasp for quite a long
time so what I think is the ideal way to
deal with grammar is first of all to
deal with it in conjunction with a lot
of input so that the grammar
explanations are relate to something
that you already have experience with or
because you have seen these structures
and you're now curious so if you're
curious about the whys why does this
happen you're more likely to be
interested and to understand the
explanations if you are hit with these
explanations without enough experience
with the language the explanations kind
of go over your head so the first thing
is you want to vary the input activities
in my opinion with the grammar learning
the second thing about grammar is or the
thing that I dislike the most about any
grammar book or where grammar is
introduced is when they ask you
questions
the assumption is because because they
have taught you something a structure a
pattern some rule that you should be
able to reproduce it that hasn't that is
never my experience all the grammar rule
or the table or the explanation does it
starts to make you aware of some
thing at least that's my experience so
that when I next read something oh yeah
it clicks in oh that's that and so
between reading it and experiencing it
and reading the rule again and then
experiencing it again slowly these
patterns become part of our you know
things that were able to understand and
eventually use so I don't like being
questioned the what and teach yourself
they have a lot of these questions and
drills they have them on the audio and
they have them in the book I never
bother but what is useful is if they
have you know questions relating to a
specific issue with the future tense or
the past tense or whatever it might be
then it is useful to go to the answer
section and read the ten example the ten
answers because the answers will all be
of the same pattern so that helps to
reinforce that pattern and so that's the
next point about a grammar book a
grammar book should be light on
explanation should have tables and
should have lots of examples so even if
a table is introduced which is a good
reference tool then you need to have
lots of examples of how these tenses are
used or how these pronouns are used and
so you read those examples and you
reread these examples and then again
when you encounter other examples of
this pattern in your listing and reading
it all starts to click in so and and I
don't like being questioned because I
don't like being forced to to reproduce
things that's part of the reason why I'm
not normally so keen to speak early
although as I'll explain a little later
in the case of Romanian I am doing that
so I don't like being asked grammar
questions I don't like being asked
comprehension questions about a text
that I've listened to I think both of
these destroy the pleasure of learning
if you ask me to talk about something
that I've read to talk if I'm reading
something on the radio Romania about you
know unemployment in Romania we can talk
about unemployment in Romania but if you
ask me to remember details of the
article and to demonstrate that I
understood it correctly well first of
all I won't remember the details and
I probably didn't understand it
correctly and it doesn't matter because
by reading the article and listening to
audio related to the article I am
getting exposure to the language and
then I with that background I can go and
read my grammar rules and my grammar
examples and it's all this constant
reinforcing circle of input review of
the grammar back to the input and so
forth one other thing I say that I
normally don't like to speak early
because there's no need to there's no
pressure if I'm learning Russian or
Czech and I'm not gonna go there for
another year
then I have no great need to start
speaking early because it's difficult to
arrange I'm not gonna change my social
life just to go out and find you know
Russians or Czechs here in Vancouver to
eat with three times a week I can have
my discussions on Skype which is fine
but then you know that's less portable
to me than just listening while I'm in
the car so that my initial period is
it's not stressful I just read a lesson
on my own time and at some point after
five six months or eight months and I
start speaking but I can't do that with
Romanian because I'm gonna be in Romania
in June and I'll only have three days
there so I've decided I'm gonna start
speaking early like I started on
Romanian two weeks ago I have now had
two discussions with a tutor at Linc and
I've signed up for more and of course
it's a real struggle to say anything but
it again it's it's it's it helps me to
notice where my gaps are I get a report
back from my tutor with about 20 phrases
that I used incorrectly
I save them they go into my flashcards I
review them it's it's it's part of my
learning process and and of course with
Romanian I can do it because even now if
I read you know if I look at what I'm
doing I'm reviewing those phrases that I
had recorded for me some other content
that has now come up come into our
library at Lake but the biggest part of
what I'm doing is I am reading news
articles from Radio Romania and
and listening to the news reports now
they're not transcripts but a lot of the
vocabulary repeats and so my ability to
my ability to understand the written
article is very high because there's so
much common vocabulary my ability to
understand the news report the
discussions or whatever is of course
much much lower but I'm doing a lot of
that to get exposed to the language and
between that and having listened to the
patterns when I speak to my tutor and if
my tutor is patient and asks me
questions we can actually get going in a
conversation with a lot of difficulty so
there you have it
grammar is important it should not be
the focus there should never be an
assumption because a grammar rule is
taught that the student should therefore
be able to reproduce it answered
correctly on tests or quizzes none of
that I don't think I mean if you look at
what happens in Canada where they teach
French in the school system they test
them every year the kids most of them
pass the French test and at the end of
it they can't speak so I'm not a fan of
testing people on grammar at all you
need brief explanations tables and lots
of examples and the understanding is
that the person looks at the grammar
reviews the grammar with not the
intention of learning it or remembering
it but as a part of the process of
becoming aware of how the language works
and that this visiting the grammar rules
and tables and seeing those examples and
then again seeing those same patterns in
meaningful context all is part of that
gradual process of getting used to how
the language works so there you have it
a bit of a discussion on grammar as it
relates to my latest adventure with
Romanian and I will be getting back to
Korean when I come back from Romania
because it is on my list and I
definitely want to achieve a decent
level in Korea so thank you for
listening bye for now